okay for people who are joining this we
are looking at functionality related to
chat in one language for version 12 this
is a package of chat tools and this is
the language level design of chat
sessions so let's let's start off um
okay so we have a menu item here new
chat session so I know um okay so what I
add here let's say chat meeting review
review meeting and then I might say so
these are new contacts but I can't okay
so I press ok here
why is it that they were not invited
until after the first message that just
seems wrong to me well the idea was that
if you accidentally cited people or if
you send it out to the wrong group of
people then you might not want them to
get immediate invitations but it's
certainly subject to be changed I think
that shouldn't be that way I mean uh it
mimics other chat systems right like you
open up a new message on your phone as
soon as you put in a contact they don't
get a message you know until you have
something to send they don't receive
anything no but but by the time you say
the thing I just did here right was I
just said new chat session I'm pressing
well we made why don't we say why
doesn't this say here start session I
mean this has to do with contact
management and that's one thing but why
don't we have a button here that says I
mean down here it could just be okay if
you're using this as a contact manager
that's a different use case then if
you're using it to start a session we're
making sense
no that's kind of understand are you
saying we now need a contact manager
interface that's divorced from who
you're chatting with no I think this is
fine I'm just saying that as soon as you
say start the session I mean if you say
cancel does it back out the contacts
that you sit no in it so oh um
look this thing here should say start
new chat session okay that should be the
header here okay
and then down here it should say start
session or something well start start
yeah and as soon as you say Scott it's
like you're often running it doesn't
have a weird you know to be invited
after you first send a message start it
start yeah okay okay so let me get rid
of this so then the invitation shows up
on everybody else's screen when you say
snow when you say start okay so what
just happened here no idea okay we have
a question on the live stream about auto
execution um does it in fact auto
execute on the other end that seems
crazy if I say for example um something
like this okay
and then I say and so I say alt what is
it doing all to return to send it oops
that didn't work Oh
return to send it I didn't work it said
old enter is there different from alt
return no it's not different and it it
works for me so I don't I don't know
what that means
well it's an option key on a Mac right
right
okay so I said that's old I've even got
an Enter key home I know it just beeps
at me
okay so what's happening that it's
totally confused just as a detail and
what happens if you use the menu item
for what is it insert similar cell below
isn't that a cell with the same style on
the insert menu okay what just happened
here I mean how did it lose my um but by
the way is there any option to get it to
go beat leap or something when it when a
new chat message comes in at this time
no should have that I think that's
actually not true it's I when Gore was
designing the channel framework here
right not really part of document needs
to be here okay okay okay
in any case there is a way to put a
sound in but I think it's just several
you know hard-coded built in DS but I
mean well so long as we can give that
you know like when you set up the
session or when you
so chart settings
okay so here it would be that dialogue
would be the place where we would have
something about notification sound make
sense sure sure that makes sense
um do we want to address that question
was in live stream about evaluation yes
I mean what's the story with that what
was the question I think the question is
does it auto evaluate if this one this
arrived on your machine what what
happened
I see lambda okay you don't see this
didn't evaluate no okay you get me why I
know so brackets oh there are what why
don't we leave the cell brackets in
there why do we have to remove the cell
brackets a little cleaner the case for
the case of something like this it seems
kind of odd to not have the cell bracket
I mean it might be reasonable in the
case of of plain text yeah plain text to
cell bracket it's kind of weird but in
this case where it's an input and an
output well I mean okay so well that
follows a pattern we use elsewhere okay
so send me a piece of code here somebody
okay so now what do I do what is my
minimal path it's kind of ugly right my
minimal path I can copy this alright and
I can put it into a new notebook Oh
actually you're gonna what the heck is
that what is that what is that garbage
that is a bug that I think has been
fixed already so this is related to the
fix to copying you know that's what you
were gonna bring up so select the cell
and if you just select the whole cell
and copy it this should work and you
should just get in it
well okay fine so J let's look at this
this J here yeah he's here we'll look at
it after the meeting this should have
worked it works for me maybe okay are we
sure that we don't want click to copy
that we don't want the whole cell to be
just be click to copy
so we tried that and I think that one of
the biggest complaints was that um you
had to click once into the notebook to
bring it in
focus and then a second time to make you
know the click to copy active in this
case you have to mess around drag
selecting but but that was regarded as
intuitive like as a natural experience
you know the the focus issue would be
different if it was a floating notebook
or floating palette but we don't do that
I don't think we want that yet the
problem was that wasn't clear that you
were you when you clicked it
you thought that you click to copy but
you actually just click to select and
then you went somewhere else and realize
you didn't have it on your clipboard
okay on our live stream are being asked
what happens if we do range of 10 to the
7 um and I just say send that
it's just going to arrive its range of
10 to the 7 right it's not evaluate nope
but now if I go to here I can't go there
and say shift-enter it's just gonna beep
at me I think it should do better than
just beeping I mean if you do
shift-enter I think it should have some
notification that says you have to copy
this out to evaluate it
I'm making sense yeah it makes sense I
mean it might you know if we're talking
about all the bells and whistles it
might even make sense for it to do the
copy for you throw it at the end of the
notebook and evaluate it you know
clearly that's what you're trying to do
well not at the end of this notebook
well maybe I don't think that's what
yeah but I do think having a button here
that says copy would be useful for the
inputs and we talked about that too the
problem is if you have multiple inputs
you want to drag select if somebody sent
four or five inputs you either have four
or five buttons that you then have to
copy each one and wanted it obviously
you don't want that and to be clear this
is not this is chat it's not really a
collaboration interface if that's the
intention we have other ideas of how to
build that point to cover here and maybe
why people are asking is whatever action
you take to evaluate ideally should be
with real intention for your own
security concerns right and and people
should understand that this is on a
sandboxed kernel anyway so we're already
addressing secure what why is it but
given that it isn't evaluating why do we
care if dynamics if you do dynamic of
delete file of whatever you know okay
then that will give me something here if
I send that you guys are in different
time zones or at least some of you are
and what will come up so if well because
the time zone is in the date objects it
oh never mind maybe maybe because I'm in
the same time zone as you but it's taken
somebody who's in a different times
doesn't say what this did I would have
to be reinvented because I was not
enabling chat services when you start
okay so how do I know who's on this chat
go to manage participants so this has
everybody you invited not everybody used
in this session we don't have like
online status right now we need that so
now what happens the list of
participants has not changed so what's
it doing I don't know I guess you could
maybe uninvite
very invite him it's not like you're
actually gonna kick him out he's not
here right okay look at that and then I
go back there this is kind of kooky and
then I say okay again why was I checked
I don't know why you were checked maybe
that's it
are you invited now now what do I have
you sent me a message so I can say
gesundheit
okay that was I mean what build is this
I'm using today's and that bug is fixed
so okay it won't mean just as is it a
bug that that's not ticklish I mean
that's not updating on your screen
either like it's not ticking up yeah
it's wrong well and is that related to
the kernel we're putting this it
shouldn't be no I mean do dynamic now in
the title nine over there Steven I'd
betting it's the same thing what is
going on here that's wrong something has
gone wrong here that should be taking up
so is it the case that I now I do so I
don't have some weird extra kernel for
the chat tools is that no that was done
away with okay fine user-facing though
you can't set it on like you can set it
in code but you can't set it from the
menus and it's not visible from the menu
right and it's not visible
okay so Andrei did you successfully get
this I did not why not and it's not
clear about what's wrong do we have ego
here have ego help I don't think he's
part of this it's already here this is
probably an edge case that just didn't
get you know somebody who was invited to
the chat
didn't make it to the chat reading them
you know
actually it's an open pockets on my v-12
list so to be fixed so if you want to
test time zone at Igor and Brady and I
did so what does it come out as could
you tell me the answer please did it
work or did it not even send it to you I
didn't get something if you added me I
did get it Igor might not have chattin
enabled either
well he better have chat enabled okay so
here I don't what is it barium Oh got it
okay you don't have to send it in but
for me to get the invite on that uh it's
sure going up at the right time zone
exactly right now you're at GMT minus
sign
yeah and it's showing 12:36 for me geez
yep okay wait a minute
it showed the same time 12:30 607 but
GMT -6 you say 13 it's showing it's
doing the right thing
Stephen it's really special time for
Brady okay but over the same but not of
a reevaluated dynamic what just happened
I just sent you a screenshot so you
could see that I don't have to explain
okay okay okay okay you know I'll make
sure that bug is reported for the
dynamic now it's nice but I can resize
that okay so how reliable do we think
all of this is or are we still full of
race conditions and things being dropped
and so on well there's certainly an open
situation where and because of how this
was originally designed we occasionally
run into messages not making it into the
saved backup index but that's that's
clearly wrong
it is it's it's an
not simple thing to fix okay so explain
the architectural mistake that was made
the architectural mistake that was made
is that these Chad indices each
particular chat index say a chat room is
backed by a single cloud object that
cloud object is updated whenever
somebody sends something to add that
send to that our race condition so we
didn't think of that
that right that was scowl that was
overlooked in the original design oh how
could that possibly have been overlooked
I mean that's a like a basic thing about
a chat system okay so what are you
telling me then because then that we
basically just can't look now it's more
than that I mean I I think that there is
a problem just with the cloud object not
handling potential collisions right well
the the rest of the issue here is that
the cloud object would be fine if there
are a way to enforce sequential updates
to it but I thought wait wait wait I
thought we had a way to do that I
thought there was a locking mechanism
that we agreed on a few months ago that
Joel kind was implementing if that's
true this was all done longer than a few
months ago if there is a locking
mechanism that we might be able to use
but I know what you're talking about and
I've been tracking that cloud ticket I
didn't see a finish but I'll check on it
now
well let's let's cut Joel here I'm
asking okay um okay because if so you're
saying if we do have a locking mechanism
for cloud objects then we can prevent
that problem here yeah yeah zooming it's
implemented in such a way that plays
nice with api's which I would think it
would be then yeah okay so if I say
create chat what is it gonna do that
brings up that
these are all that I make no guarantees
that these are fully fleshed out
functions at all you know at some point
there should be a create chat that
actually takes arguments and let you
fill this stuff out this was
all stopgap okay so brings up a chat
session dialogue it's basically what
that does correct that's exactly what it
does yep okay by the way I'm saving
these things back into this yeah what's
the that's good okay so do we have a
workflow that describes you know so the
use cases that we are aware of for this
include things like classroom settings
it includes for example the
live-streaming that I'm trying to do
with these nks book coding things where
I would like people I mean what is the
best path for having people who are
watching a live stream be able to either
send code in or receive code either hi
um okay we get an answer to that
question first what's the right
mechanism in this to do that using this
yes using this for classrooms no I'm
asking well both put it's basically the
same question I mean if if you don't
care who sees what then like if you
don't care who sees what codes coming in
from anybody then you could just make an
open chat room that you tell people what
it is they can join and leave as they
will and they just send stuff and
everybody else is that even called a
chatroom why isn't that just the channel
broker scenario where people have
subscribed to the channel because we
need because we need aux for where that
stuff arrives yeah okay well sometimes
that might just want to be in a person's
notebook also for the competition
situation we had of a palette that there
is no notebook gathering everybody's
stuff they choose to insert it into a
notebook that they have open or copy
from it to send you know so that's
another scenario okay
let's let me ask the question of Joel
here
this chat stuff is kind of totally
broken because of various kinds of
locking that aren't there the question
was I thought we had designed a lock
mechanism for cloud objects some time
ago is that not correct not not quite
there's no finished design there was a
couple of ideas what was the parent mind
mate remind me what the what the
function that we had talked about for
that was that's what I'm trying to look
up right now I have my own notes but I
don't think that's what we're talking
about do I have to find it myself
you can look I'm continuing to look for
the ticket so I found my own notes I
mean aren't we talking about the two
generals problem yeah but but we have a
mechanism for dealing with this we
invented a mechanism for dealing with
this
[Music]
and it's not fair to characterize it as
totally somewhat broken it's really
that's just for the archival record of
the chat it doesn't my understanding is
it doesn't impact the actual live
chatting that takes place is that right
right that's right that's just how the
live chatting just happens over the
channel framework that doesn't involve
cloud objects
my object protect was the what happened
well it's there's some there's some
design for it there are some problems
that identified some problems to be
solved in implementation mainly to do
with if the lock gets removed
notifying whoever's holding the lock
reliably okay so is that is the
intention that it works like symbol
protecting an done protecting where in
order to so if you wanted to change it
the method would be the IP on a
protected cloud object you to unprotect
that change it and protect it again or
is it implemented somehow differently or
design the function interface was you
supply an object and then some code to
evaluate under lock right so that code
would lock that cloud object for the
joints more like a board protect I see
okay well so does it need a meeting to
figure out more detail about how this
should work I think so you know okay
okay
well all right fine
so can we get that requested please
Brady can you request that who is the
project manager for this yeah who's the
project manager dealing with this is
that Matt I think okay okay okay great
well I think that several convenient
from you Joel thanks okay
okay
what is this so women if I say create
chat room so are you telling me that
there's a global name a for example so
okay the difference no it's clearly
about the difference between these two
things when you go to file new chat or
use create chat those are kind of
one-off chats there you start them with
people when everyone quits them that
chat ceases to be create chatroom
creates a persistent chat such that if
nobody's in it it doesn't care it's
still there but to answer your specific
question that short name a is yes that
is global globally unique oh wow that's
really weird I mean if you had a
different way to make sure that they
couldn't get confused we could consider
it but well I don't know it's not why it
isn't the URL type thing I mean that is
this URL is something completely
grotesque right
but in general it's like going to
somebody's API or something I mean this
chatroom should just have a URL that
includes for example I don't know the
initiating users base or a UUID sure but
then how would you join it yeah that a
is the way that people join the room
they in the file new chat you know they
put a in there you could say you're a
web browser how enough do you go to a
website well the answer is you type in
the URL and it's the same thing here you
want to join a chat session you have to
type its URL basically I mean the fact
that you can just say I want to go to
chat session a is a completely non
scalable thing that doesn't seem to make
much sense to me right I mean unless you
are in yeah I mean you should be able to
alias that perhaps but it seems to me
that the actual name just like this name
except this is a particular grotesque
what happens if I go there it's just not
a splat but oh yeah
generic page and if the channel broker
was using MQTT would that be I mean this
right now is even exists because the
channel broker is using HTTP is that
true or he go maybe you can answer that
yes the fact that it's an HTTP cloud
object is that not hey architecture for
mqtt will not change everything will
remain the same I'm not getting the
question so there will be a URL in HTTP
Kyle URL yes it would be not HTTPS but
MQTT is Samsung no no that's what I'm
asking because this is an HTTP transport
thing right
giant Skanda but it's not a URL for
example we can imagine that a chatroom
could have a home page in a web page
just like a cloud object can have a you
know has a web presence and qtt does not
have a web presence any does not but
reach then does okay we also have a
notion of there being a limit to how
many rooms any user can create I believe
that's currently enforced yeah it's not
built-in but we certainly have discussed
it I mean III think the number of rooms
at this point are small enough that it
hasn't really mattered to hands yeah but
I mean I can just write it write a loop
I'll write it loose right right you like
me to blow this up I'll just blow it up
right now
you'll be the first person right but we
know we have to get set in that limit we
have it on our to-do list yeah I mean
we're trying to limit developments right
now just because when mqtt comes out you
know we'll be rebuilding a lot of this
that's the mqtt server being built um
what is the status of the mqtt server
[Music]
but I don't know the current status
sorry who did you say jesse reports to
bob bob reports to me they are working
on it right it is in progress I don't
have an exact status though
couple of people on the live stream is
saying um that they would like a tabbed
interface for multiple chats it's not
obvious to me how that would work
because if you if there's another chat
going on how do you even know I mean you
have to have all kinds of elaborate UX
about flashing the tab and things if
there's a second chat but I mean I guess
I guess for example you know rocket chat
or something you I don't think even know
do you if there's a you have multiple
tabs for multiple chat sessions how do
you
know if there's a message on a chat
session that you don't currently whose
tagline currently be a little alert yeah
and then I mean there's also you know
the bad rap icon which is really nice
this on max at least just to see that
there's something going on in one of
your windows in that app okay I will say
if you have adopted the interface for
notebooks then that chip you'll be
resolved automatically I agree with that
that was where I was going with it all
right fair enough okay so okay there's a
question about whether this can be used
for collaboration between Mathematica
users for example in a pair programming
scenario to some extent I don't think
this is the best solution for that your
collaboration notes that would be better
well it's not clear how those would
possibly work with them I mean in the
cloud it's much more obvious how that
would work
right I mean you have a trade off do you
really want some other person to be able
to essentially grab the notebook that
you are currently editing well or do we
have an idea you're saying with the
channel framework we could in principle
say I just don't know how that will
possibly work I think it's really
Bradley had mapped out some ideas for
that
I don't know that wasn't really the
point of what we're doing here we're
trying to settle the I mean I think
these are very very weak these these
things that we have here I think this is
you know I think it's sort of usable
it's very the language level stuff is
bare-bones make no bones about it and
you you've described you know a lot of
aspirations about the language level
stuff and we have those notes there in
your ILD folders yeah what is this only
the run creator other users will only
see messages from themselves and
moderators that's the teacher-student
scenario yep
prompted response okay so only teachers
see all the students messages and
students can't see each other's messages
you have to be moderator level for
everybody to see yeah so have we tried
these things I mean I will use them for
the live coding last year and yeah and
there was a horrible I have I had
somebody use them in a classroom maybe
either into the last year was not a
horrible disaster it worked just fine
actually yeah no no the year before last
worked quite smoothly with these
features such as they were they weren't
necessarily designed for competition but
they worked as they needed to
this year we designed an actual
competition palette and system that went
beyond using the chat interface okay the
first year of the competition we decided
to try and use these tools a week or two
before the conference and as I warned
you it was likely to fail and it sort of
did but then the Igor had some working
examples that's that played well for the
event you know that weren't so much
based on
our chat interface all right let's see
what else we have to look at here
because I think this is I mean this
seems
modify room moderators list so
previously there just wasn't a way for
people to update the moderators on for a
sense of prompted response chat room and
that the it's really pretty necessary
after the fact otherwise they would have
had to delete the chat room and recreate
it with a new list of moderators set
options on what would this create chat
room returned they returned to some
weird channel object it should return
some kind of blob that's a chatroom
object right which contains the cloud
object it also has other stuff and then
the correct way to deal with the change
in the moderator list is some kind of
set options on the chat object chat room
object yeah that makes sense
I think that's the correct design rather
than some weird function for modified
room moderators list right well then the
question is do we want to expose this
experimentally for now and let people
actually do this thing or do we want to
just not expose anything and do it right
expose it now knowing that we're going
to have to change how we do it later
well I think that function okay what are
the things that you're doing here so
this is just stupidly wrong if I might
say so I mean this is this room
moderators should obviously be some sub
value of the object right if I'm if I'm
given that design then that's fine but I
mean my question still stands we're not
going to get chat room object for verse
12 we have a chance to get these I mean
these are actually already implemented
it's just we have a chance to expose
them so you're saying that create chat
returns a cloud object that what you're
basically saying create chat room
returns a channel object yeah or well
it's a cloud object that is a channel
object create chat returns nothing
create chat just opens up the dialogue
bizarrely even when you press okay in
the dialogue it doesn't so does it do
that in a blocking way or does it do
that in an asynchronous way create chat
is the same thing basically as going to
file new chat session it's using your
front end it is not kernel block so
that's wrong I mean it shouldn't be
called create chat
well create chat would you know once
this is further designed create chat
will actually take arguments does that
change your statement that create chat
shouldn't be called look the only thing
that I don't understand what the
difference between create okay they okay
create chat should return some kind of
chat object I mean how can it not return
something right now what is the handle
to the chat that you're talking about it
does exist but it is not made at you
know it was when you were evaluate
create chat it starts that dialogue
right there is no chat yet because you
haven't started it yet you know as we
start that's just wrong okay it's just
wrong it should create chat should it
can go through the dialogue or you can
give it an association that has the
information that's in the dialogue and
it should return a chat object okay and
when it brings up the dialogue it should
be a blocking thing that just allows you
to you know fill it in as a dialogue
just for as a courtesy so to speak and
then return the chat object at the end
and then that chat object should
presumably have some kind of chat
execute type thing that allows you to
whatever actions there are in the chat
like like adding something you know like
like sending something from the chat it
should allow you to just do that I mean
send message for example arguably should
take a chat object to the first argument
and send the message on that chat
session yep right I think that's the
right design now and it's pretty alluded
to a lot of that stuff has been defined
it's just a waiting excision okay
well has it been okay but but so your
question right now is how can we
cauterize these rather horrifying I mean
so create chat room is returning just a
cloud object which is so wrong um and
the question is
I mean we could have entity thing you're
talking about that it would create is
not something my team has ever built so
that gets no it's really quite easy I
mean that's a that's just returning um
it's just returning something with an
association that contains this I mean it
would literally internally it would just
be chat object-- of and then some
Association which has a bunch of
information including you know broke a
location or something whatever it is ro
that that cloud object thing makes sense
but is there a standard rendering of
that that yes yes yes you have to hook
into the UM the standard object thingy
right same thing that they'd have been
used the search result objects things
like that the great that's correct
correct and then um you know there
should be the you know an l-value it
should be possible to say chat object of
well it would actually be two things
chat object and chatroom object okay and
chatroom object could have a moderators
there and then you could say something
like you know change that moderators to
blah blah blah blah blah if you own
enough if you own the chatroom to the
point where you could do that why
couldn't those be the same kind of
object I mean it's like we talked about
chat session objects last last time that
we talked about this months ago I don't
know if that could service one I mean I
don't see my chat object in chat room
object has to be different at the
language level I thought that this was a
specific chat session as opposed to a
location for chats to occur in am i
confused there I mean a chat room is a
persistent thing a chat session is a
thing that happens for a certain period
of time and then closes down again
it's good yeah but well I think I need a
thinking to think about a little bit
more but a chatroom I mean I at the
point at the time that you're
interacting with it are they you know
what interactions would you do on a an
object that you wouldn't want to do to a
session or that you couldn't do to a
session persistent object I mean I'm
amused by Ethan on the live stream
saying this functionality exemplifies a
win skis law I had not remember what
solinsky's Laura is it's the law that
every program attempts to expand until
it can read mail well I'm certainly
surprised at how complex this simple
concept of I'm talking to somebody else
gets in terms of all the options and
configurations needed yes not agree just
think what it must have been like what
people were first making AOL Instant
Messenger it's surprising it ever worked
um yeah I don't even know if it was the
first chat thing um okay so okay so what
are we gonna do right now with this
[Music]
I mean you know this is simply a package
but I think oh boy what other features
are there other than the moderators are
there other other things I mean this is
going to the short name of the of the
that's very weird well and that's all
contingent on using that as the unique
identifier for one of these rooms if we
go to a URL then it would be that right
um so I mean you can modify or view the
moderators you can you know another
thing that we were missing that we added
for twelve was being able to view all of
your chat rooms all the chat rooms that
you've made um it's just chat rooms yep
that's it I've never done this before or
you've deleted them I mean if you did
this before we released eleven three
then we probably cleaned the list when
it was when this was officially released
so anything that you've done before
maybe uh got scrubbed okay um look this
stuff is pretty messy um you know in
terms of
gonna do with these two functions I am
kind of almost in the you know if we had
a chatroom information function but the
problem is it's only got one thing in it
I don't know look best thing I can
suggest we should rename this chat room
moderators because that's at least a
little bit less bizarre okay yeah um and
then here is that modify or what is this
to be okay so this is set chatroom
moderators and why one of them gets a
list and the other one doesn't I have no
idea Tim say so this is chatroom
moderators and set chatroom moderators
it's hardly beautiful but it's at least
not horrifying it's better than yeah um
okay so again I'm trying to understand
the roadmap for this so do we have I
mean there's some things like the
existence of a sensible channel broker
the locking of cloud objects
dependencies okay the cleaning up of the
UX for all of this I mean and I mean
clearly eventually we'll need something
um talking about this win skis law that
everything expands until it till it can
read mail um I think the another
principle would be that um everything
eventually needs a general purpose AI in
it I mean we need to have you know it
should be the case that there can be a
bot in here yeah we've also started
discussing chop off functions before
so then after twelve I should I'm sorry
but by the way what that is like is like
the mail receiver function functionality
it's a chat receiver functionality right
that you say in this chatroom uh you
know I want to attach to this chatroom
or maybe it's actually it's a chatroom
responder function
and it's part of and anybody who can
join the chatroom could also have a bot
join the chat room and a chat room
responder function specifics their
machine you know we were originally
talking about BOTS I was thinking that
BOTS would be at least from the UX
perspective just a thing that you would
invite using the same you know at the
book and a work I mean the but has got
to be well I'm not saying that it would
be set up the same way when you invite
it but when you invite our BOTS the
function knows that it's a bot and so it
sets it up using I mean we have channel
receiver function already which is kind
of what you're discussing yeah I did and
previously you define chat responder
function okay so after 12 I should have
a design review meeting about this and
the waist forward and yeah and I think
it's really important can we please
identify with clarity the use cases here
that we're talking about and make sure
that they're actually clean the list in
fact in a project list that I just made
in the last couple of days there's a
list of use cases that I'm aware of for
this let's see um call on the live
stream comments on Facebook Messenger
and its interact with chat BOTS I have
no idea what's involved in doing that I
have no idea whether you can have I mean
we had looked at in fact we had
preliminary versions of chats bots on
kik I think also people have done them
for telegram um and I don't know whether
we have do we have one for rocket chat
no I mean I've seen them implemented for
lots of things particularly people
calling the Wolfram Alpha API um in a
chat session I have to say I don't think
that it's been a runaway success in any
these cases I mean obviously we've also
got things like our tweeter program
mechanism on Twitter um I mean we don't
have any internally with our own chat
systems inside the company oh and I
think people have plans with them on
slack also um but I think I mean I don't
know what um yeah I mean particularly
with natural language understanding
there are some fairly interesting things
that could be done with BOTS and I mean
I think interest waxes and wanes for
those things um and actually it's
something we should add to the list of
you know what chat bot functionality do
we think we're trying to support and one
of the use cases for that okay um so by
the way to get rid of this chat session
what do I do i I mean do I just close it
or what what do I do and does that does
that close it for everybody or what is
it what happens then so what should
happen now is you should have you should
be able to close the window and then you
leave the chat that will not end the
chat for everybody um it ends when
everybody leaves it the last person
shuts off the lights seconds so second
the last person right because they're by
yourself that it's no longer a chat
really what have you added somebody else
no so so what once there's only one
person left
the docs thought the top is stripped out
and it's just a notebook appropriate
messaging that says well how let's see
it happen why don't you guys drop yeah
usually in the hamburger menu click on
exit chat well yeah I have somebody else
in there okay well why don't I go to
marriage participants and just kick
everybody out
where is mash participants why isn't it
coming up okay I'm just kicking
everybody out
okay
no I why does it say this I want to chat
with myself but so what I mean what why
change that because after all I can
easily go back in and add somebody I
might have look it's a it's a corner
case where you have a big meeting
everybody's left you're about to start
another meeting different people are
gonna join I I don't think that that's I
think it's completely wrong it's like
the the famous example of a really
bizarre design decision is the UNIX mail
program where if you say mail and then
the you know the name of one or more
people it'll send mail to those people
if you say mail with no arguments it'll
read your mail so you know that if you
write a program which is sending out a
you know notification for example and it
so happens that it sends a notification
to zero people it'll disgorge mail all
over the screen sure I mean but maybe
the question then is if you are using
this in a way that it spans meetings and
is kind of persistent why wouldn't you
just use a chatroom well yeah I think
that that's part of the whole UX design
review that we need to do on this okay
all right well listen I think we've I
think we've cauterized this enough for
the 12 hour release its experimental
it's a package what it is and as part of
it going forward
you know the hope is that it will become
system-level and you know as part of
that it would be cleaned up and fair
enough to load the package all right I
think we're wrapping up here thanks
everybody
thank you folks on the live stream see
y'all soon